katholische sexualität für einsteiger
mit internet jugend wie carl xvi
recht
ich grüße euch ja holy holy ist schön
dass immer wieder vorbei klickt ja ich
bin cool
das merkt ja schon daran dass ich hier
auf den tisch sitze und ich sage ohne
rot zu werden
sex habe ich einfach so auf 666 knick
knack deshalb wird ein raus spiel ja
wissen viele nicht darf ich als priester
sagen ich dachte nicht machen wegen
achtung beschreiben zölibat lateinisch
für bundes verbot ist nicht leicht ich
meine wir alle haben die dornenvögel
geguckt und gedacht lecken ich werde
also hier diesen mit chamberlain und ich
von der bettkante stoßen nicht nur usa
mut zur liebe steht schon in der bibel
steht nicht drin
doch ja apostel paulus erster korinther
wenn du heiratest beginnst du jedoch
keine sünde nur werdet ihr als
verheiratete besonderen belastung
ausgesetzt seien und das würde ich euch
gerne ersparen kurz gesagt die alle
nervt ja noch im achten jahrhundert
waren deutschen bischöfe verheiratet
gott furchtbare zeit ja wird es in ruhe
was weiß ich ein paar ketzer verbrennen
und dann erst konnte mit dem
überspringen
meine ganz ehrlich was hat der zölibat
und unterdrückte sexualität mit
missbrauch zu tun höhe
ja ja gute sind doch egal ich meine wir
haben so schon total modernen papst
angeschafft was wollte er noch von uns
ein journalist fragt den papst wie
eltern sich verhalten sollen wenn ihr
kind homosexuelle neigungen zeige wenn
es sich in der kindheit zeigt kann man
noch einiges machen mit psychiatrie oder
sehen wie die dinge sind die klasse
hauptsache die heiraten wenn gott
gewollt hätte dass priester heiraten
warum hat er denn dann die haushälterin
erschaffen
alle und danach mit gebügelt die
psychologie digital erlebt gebrechen
[Applaus]
[Musik]